all right the National Football League
has been the recipient of widespread
criticism in the last few years for a
variety of issues involving the safety
of its players and players protesting
during the national anthem to protest
racial injustice along with fans
ditching their cable subscriptions those
stories have led to a steady decline in
TV ratings however the league is still
making money and remains an integral
part of American culture a recent
article in Bloomberg Businessweek
explores the league's existential crisis
and whether it's really a crisis at all
Evan Nobby Williams is a sports business
reporter for Bloomberg News and the
co-anchor of that story and joins us
here to date right writer
it's a co-anchor in there maybe thinking
Joey co-author right when you talk about
a head into film this is it's still
gonna be able to watch football change
the channel right so so okay so there
the NFL's taking this major hit right
everyone acknowledges that ratings are
down tremendously for the league still
making a ton of money how do those two
work together yeah it's kind of what we
call it this existential crisis when
you're King everybody wants to criticize
the king and the NFL is king not just in
sports but entertainment the NFL is the
premier entertainment property in the US
right now and it's very easy to
criticize when Colin Kaepernick takes a
knee it gets criticism from both the
left and the right side of its fans
concussions another big one you know
that is an issue that is concerning both
the people that want to see the game
cleaned up and also the people who love
the violent aspects of the game and all
of that we're seeing play out in ratings
yeah Phil makes all its money it costs
more and more money to for an ad in
during the Superbowl exactly area
networks pay more including CBS a more
and more each time that the rights are
up to to broadcast the games and that's
because it's reaching so many people
there's average 15 million people watch
each NFL game that's down from years
past but as you talk about Digital
Trends people moving towards away from
their traditional cable boxes we're
speaking on a network that didn't exist
five years ago and that's because people
are changing the way they watch
television and the NFL remains the king
of the TV world so can the ratings dip
that is affecting the NFL right now
benefit other sports leagues or even
other companies because
it's as we point out in the introduction
there is there has been some blowback to
the Colin Kapernick and the you know
what some people might term a
controversy but others call justice
where football players are taking a knee
during the playing of the national
anthem to protest racial injustice I
note that CNBC has a report out today
that says Nike stock is at an all-time
high and expected to go even higher even
though there were some who were sort of
saying it was going to suffer because of
their ads yeah sure so in the immediacy
the only sports property that's really
growing its TV audience right now is the
NBA and there's no question that as the
NFL continues to suffer a little bit the
NBA is picking up some market share that
said we're talking about two very
different sized
organizations right the NFL as a 15
billion dollar industry the NBA is an
eight or nine billion dollar league so
you know you're talking still about a
huge gap the NBA certainly is going to
pick up some of the people who may be
turning away from the NFL but the NBA
would certainly love to have the NFL's
viewership drivers so is there any
evidence like the president has asserted
occasionally that the protests during
the national anthem have actually had
any impact on the popularity or the
viewership of the NFL no the simple
answer is no and I have a DejaVu part of
my job where late summer every year the
the Packers the Green Bay Packers
declare their revenue and every year I
get on the call and the Packers
president Mark Murphy he goes well it's
been a good year revenue is up for the
14 15 16 I think this year was the 16th
straight time he said that there was no
evidence other owners I've talked to
haven't seen a direct tie quite yet the
problem with with what had Colin did and
the way the NFL handled it is that you
see groups on both sides that are angry
you know there was a graphic that was
shared on Twitter last year with all the
NFL sponsors saying boycott these
sponsors if you're angry about the
kneeling situation you had people on the
right who were angry that that players
were kneeling at all sharing that
graphic and you had people on the Left
who felt like the ownership and Roger
Goodell were reacting poorly right they
were also sharing the ground right you
know it's the strange bedfellows where
you have people on both ends that are
you know that are upset with the league
and that puts the league in a tough
position but still watching football on
the left
sponsors if they're getting the money
and the advertising dollars I mean you
saw the chart the dollars are going you
know it's a straight line up but I'd be
interested to know what the demographics
are because I suspect that not only are
younger people not tuning in as much
because of folks like Colin Kaepernick
who are raising awareness of a very
important issue and also the safety
issue when it comes to football players
I mean I know that's one of the reasons
that a lot of the people that I'm
friends with who watch football our
entire lives and said you know why I
don't want to contribute to an
organization that is potentially
life-threatening for worry no when I
think about that wasn't you know we
talked about the beginning about it you
know football is a Americana right and
so I think about the parents with young
boys who will not now think of football
as an option as a sport and an
extracurricular activity because of that
and how much it sort of goes against how
we feel about the way we treat each
other as Americans we don't watch them
beat each other up and the ratings dip
is nothing compared to the dip we've
seen in youth participation in rapaho
that's it and the way that applies to
the NFL is up for debate I've talked to
owners who are concerned that people are
playing football less and less at the
youth level I've also talked to owners
who think that youth participation is
not and not necessary for you to love
the NFL very few NFL fans played
football when they were younger and they
still believe that they can get people
who didn't play the game but necessarily
want to watch it as you said there are
certainly people out there who feel
guilty just watching the sport as it is
because they're gaining a better
understanding of what's doing to these
young men who are taking the field that
is something the NFL will have to deal
with and they're doing that I mean
they're making the game they're trying
to make the game safer you know they're
changing rules things that were not a
penalty two or three years ago are a
penalty now and again as we talk about
strange bedfellows there are people that
are upset on that on both sides you know
people want to see the game safer other
people love the violence of the game
they love the NFL because people are
running full-speed and bashing their
heads against each other right and if
that is not allowed maybe the NFL and
this is the big question this is the
existential crisis can the NFL be safe
and also be compelling to watch and I
don't think we've answered that question
yet either way they're still making
money lots of people are still watching
no matter what the
president wins a brochure Evan no V
Williams thank you very much